have you ever had an imaginary friend
maybe you did when you were very little
and then forgot all about it that first
friend you ever had the one you told all
your secrets your fears the one you
trusted and listened to for advice when
you weren't sure if something was right
or wrong the one you swore you would
carry with you everywhere you went that
sacred pact that slowly drifted into
forgot well what if those Imaginary
Friends weren't imaginary after all just
what were they where did they come from
and are they still out there somewhere
waiting for us to think them back into
existence today's Story begins not in
our childhood but deep inside a hidden
underground facility where a man sits in
his enclosed habitat protected by
round-the-clock armed SCP Foundation
security Personnel this man is a
middle-aged normal human being without
any unique physical characteristics he
is not a member of the o5 council nor is
he a foreign dignitary or a person in
any position of political power and yet
the safety and protection of this man's
life are a Paramount importance and what
threatens that safety is the subject of
today's video The Entity that hunts him
scp-1447 also known as the tulpa
scp-1447-1 is the foundation's
designation for the floating quasi a
physical humanoid entity that resembles
the appearance of a traditional Buddhist
monk but whose face appears perpetually
distorted the word tulpa is a Tibetan
word that means emanation or magical
creation the idea being that a
practitioner of deep meditation could
focus hard enough to conjure a physical
manifestation of a thought or an idea
scp-1447-1 is a ketter class entity
currently being held in an airtight 2.5
by 2.5 by 2.5 meter concrete container
suspended above the ground in Bay four
the cell is to be repeatedly reinforced
with steel plating with regular
inspections for any damage to the
containment structure any cracks or
breaks in
scp-1447-1's containment are to be
reported immediately and considered a
breach level event this is due to
scp-1447-1's ability to insert itself
into breaches and cracks as small as 200
micrometers in diameter meaning that
even the smallest crack in its
containment enclosure will almost
certainly lead to
scp-1447-1's escape while the tulpa
seems uninterested in killing anyone
other than the facilities previously
mentioned resident it will not hesitate
in killing any Personnel that prevents
it from achieving its principal goal
scp-1447-1 appears unaffected by Small
Arms fire from standard issue Foundation
sidearms seemingly impervious to any
physical means of damage however
suppressive fire from High Caliber
Weaponry does seem to have an effect on
scp-1447-1 appearing to temporarily
disrupt the projection of its physical
form this concentration of High Caliber
fire has proven to be effective in
forcing
scp-1447-1 back into its containment
enclosure explosives also seem to have
the positive effect of completely
dissipating as
cp-1447's physical presence however this
has the undesired side effect of the
entity then materializing somewhere else
in the immediate vicinity this
re-materialization is not impeded by
physical structures sometimes allowing
the tulpa to bypass defensive positions
and obstacles entirely although
scp-1447-1 appears on security footage
to hover slowly towards its intended
target
scp-1447's behavior and containment is
quite the opposite for 20 hours of the
day the tulpa moves around its
containment cell at a staggering 200
kilometers per hour punching dents into
its enclosure hoping to create a
weakness in the structure that it can
exploit it requires no rest and appears
to have Limitless stamina despite
researchers best efforts to film
scp-1447-1 using a high-speed camera its
face is still impossible to see as it
remains in perpetual motion and only
visible as a blur to the human eye
attempts to communicate with
scp-1447-1 have been inconclusive when
asked question the tulpa will respond
with unintelligible garbled responses
that when slowed down appear to be
traditional Tibetan mantras repeated
hundreds of times a second
scp-1447-1 does seem to exhibit signs of
intelligence and even deceit as on one
occasion it was observed goading
security Personnel into attacking it
with explosive devices as it was near
the entrance of another scp's enclosure
leading to a double breach event
scp-1447-2 is the designation given to
the man currently confined to his
quarters inside the containment site he
is a software and Hardware engineer and
entrepreneur whose name has been
redacted from official records we will
refer to him from Huron simply as Steve
the following is information the subject
gave SCP Foundation staff willingly
Steve was an accomplished man excelling
at everything he did and finding a great
level of success in the tech sector as a
developer and entrepreneur and yet with
all the riches and Fame that his success
brought him he found himself wanting
more his obsessiveness for a sense of
meaningful fulfillment led him to drive
away loved ones and dive further into
his work creating a vicious cycle of
self-isolation leaving him with a
greater sense of unfulfillment from his
life one day Steve came to the
realization that what he needed was to
split away from the reality he had
created for himself he needed to find
peace and he knew he couldn't do it
where he currently was he packed a bag
and without a second thought decided to
leave everything behind without saying a
word to anyone about where he was going
but where was he going he had thought to
himself following a trend of westerners
traveling to Asia to find a new sense of
Enlightenment Steve boarded the playing
to Ching Hai Province China where he had
joined an order of monastic monks as he
did with most aspects of his life he
threw himself entirety into the practice
dressing like the brothers of the order
in the traditional monastic Garb and
even electing to shave his head bare
switching to a vegetarian diet and
learning the Tibetan mantras he put his
sole effort into learning the art of
deep meditation vowing to truly split
away from the repetitive unfulfilling
life he had chosen to leave behind
during one particular lesson Steve
learned from an elder brother at the
monastery about the concept of a tulpa a
method where a person enters deep
focused meditation to conjure a physical
visual manifestation of a specific
thought or emotion being new to the
practice at the time Steve couldn't find
himself thinking of anything but the
image of a laughing Buddha he was used
to seeing every time he entered a local
Chinese restaurant back in the United
States he remembered how the image made
him feel welcome how the look of Joy on
the Buddha's face brought a look of joy
to his own explaining this to the
brothers at the monastery they promptly
corrected him that this image is not an
image of the Buddha as in the sense of
the Buddha being a single defined deity
but just one of the many interpretations
of Buddha The Laughing Buddha is
particularly a cultural symbol of luck
and abundance the monks asked Steve to
picture something else when attempting
to visualize a tulpa such as an emotion
that has taken form and shape but try as
he could Steve had become fixated on the
image of the popular laughing Buddha and
could do little to imagine anything else
on his own Steve meditated persistently
in this endeavor truly expecting success
and working towards it with a fervent
drive he put into every project in his
life and to the amazement of himself and
the brothers of the monastery his tulpa
slowly began to manifest it was small at
first only an image that he could see he
didn't think much of it not thinking
that he had created anything real he
believed the image of the Laughing
Buddha in front of him was just an
overactivation of the visual centers of
his brain most likely due to the strain
from long hours of meditation deciding
to humor his imagination he began
treating the tall but like he would any
brother of the temple speaking to it out
loud and showing it respect and
inclusion it was like having his own
imaginary friend yet over time the tulpa
began to become more than just an image
it began to have a physical effect on
objects around him a bucket kicked over
a chair pulled back as a brother went to
sit down the imaginary friend was now
more like a mischievous invisible
prankster but still only one he could
see the brothers began to grow weary of
the tulpa and with it grew weary of the
Foreigner that had brought it into
existence meanwhile Steve had become
amazed at his level of success he began
to wonder if he could manifest other
thoughts into existence he began to
think about his life his career his
level of success he began to think about
how he could apply himself to impart his
will on reality how he wanted more he
focused on this goal of meditation and
yet could not help but find frustration
in his efforts it didn't help that the
brothers of the monastery now openly
presented him Steve's demeanor began to
change and become less optimistic and
more obsessed with the memory of the
repetitive monotony of his old life
before coming to the monastery his tulpa
too began to change no longer fat with
joy its appearance began to thin what
was once an embodiment of laughter and
happiness began to morph into a darker
more mischievous entity the pranks too
became more dangerous the tulpa began
leaving buckets of scalding hot water
above door frames for unsuspecting monks
to walk through it then began filling
the sandals of monks with snakes
thankfully for the brothers of the
monastery snakes weren't poisonous until
suddenly on one particular occasion they
were a pair of fayette's vipers appeared
in the sandals of a brother of the
monastery venomous snakes that could
only be found hundreds of miles away in
the south of Tibet in a region Steve had
never heard of and had never been to it
was an impossibility for him to have
given birth to the manifestation of this
act without its requisite knowledge did
this mean the tulpa had gained some
means of self-actualization could it
contemplate its own sentience seeking to
learn more answers about the nature of
the tulpa Steve studied the teachings of
the Buddha and the quests for
enlightenment about Nirvana and the end
to the cycle of death and rebirth in his
mind Steve began to intertwine those
ideas with the memory of the mundanity
of his previous life and the feelings
that lingered in his stomach of it being
unfulfilling and empty how he had
desperately wanted the daily cycle of
mundanity to end how he wanted peace
little did he know in doing so he was
creating a manifestation with the
express goal of ending his life as Steve
began to enter longer and deeper
sessions of meditation the tulpa began
to grow more self-actualizing and
independent of his will it became harder
to control Maleficent and one day Steve
realized he could no longer picture The
Laughing Buddha that had once filled him
with joy from that moment on the toppa's
face became unrecognizable and was no
longer in a fixed state but in constant
movement so that no facial features
could be visible it was that night the
monks had caught the tulpa holding a
knife to Steve's throat channeling their
meditative power of actualization they
managed to collectively banish the tulpa
from the monastery but it was not for
long the toppa began to follow Steve
wherever he went a physical embodiment
of his wish to end the repeating cycle
of his life and bring him peace peace by
means of the extinguishing of his life
the existence of
scp-1447-1 was first brought to the
attention of foundation staff when Steve
arrived at site-73 seeking Sanctuary
from the tulpa he had been running from
it is unclear to Foundation staff how
the software Mogul came to know of the
location of site-73 all that could be
gained from questioning him on the
matter is that he received the
information from the monks at a lamisary
in qinghai Province China Steve was
given the designation
scp-1447-2 because of his relation to
the entity and then placed in Secure
confinement at the facility two days
later security Personnel made contact
with the entity when it attacked the
facility in search of the tech Mogul
resulting in the death of two agents the
attacks from scp-1447 ceased when Steve
was evacuated via airlift to London and
then later moved again to site-60 in
just three weeks after this change the
tulpa had already caught up with Steve
attacking the facility and becoming
enraged by the interference from
security Personnel slaughtering
countless members of SCP staff in its
wake it is here at this facility that
the members of security Personnel were
first able to use High Caliber Firepower
to push back the topaz Advance into a
makeshift concrete enclosure which would
eventually come to be
scp-1447-1's current attainment cell Dr
rolfus an SCP researcher was the first
to interview Steve after assigning him
to the designation
scp-1447-2 he was given this designation
when Foundation staff realized that the
person known as Steve real name redacted
had in fact never left the United States
for Ching Hai Province and had been
leading his life as a successful Tech
Mogul without any notable Interruption
researchers became unsure whether Steve
was in fact who he said he was or
instead an entity similar to
scp-1447-1 when confronted with images
of his doppelganger in news and media
reports living out his life and assuming
his identity
scp-1447-2 was unable to explain the
anomaly and asserted that he was the
true original version of himself
suggesting that a rival technology
company or even his own for that matter
may have hired a lookalike to take his
place as head of the business in his
absence when the public counterpart of
SC
1447-2 was recently found deceased
testing of the subject's hair and tissue
showed no anomalous characteristics of
any kind it is believed as cp-1447-1 may
have been somehow responsible for the
mysterious death a prevailing Theory
regarding the existence of
scp-1447-2's counterpart posits that
Steve may have been in fact able to
manifest two tulpas into existence Steve
may have suffered a traumatic mental
breakdown that perhaps unbeknownst to
him led to the creation of a secondary
personality that later manifested itself
into existence following his training in
meditation and practice in creating a
tulpa it may have been this dual
manifestation that led to Steve's loss
of control of
scp-1447-1 in the first place
scp-1447-2 remains adamant that he has
the power to put an end to the tulpa's
existence through the application of
methods of concentration and meditative
practice scp4 1447-2 dedicates at the
very least four hours a day to
meditating on the following topics
scp-1447-1 is getting weaker
scp-1447-1 is dying
scp-1447-1 is unable to maintain
physical form to his credit Foundation
researchers have observed
scp-1447-1 is severely curtailed during
periods in which its counterpart engages
in focused meditation on the abolition
of the tulpa during these periods as
cp-1447-1 is almost completely still
adopting the vajra meditation position
it is believed through
self-actualization the topa can meditate
on its own existence counteracting the
meditative attacks against its ability
to exist in its manifested form to Aid
in this endeavor Foundation staff have
considered different ways to disrupt
scp-1447-1's meditation at first they
suggested a hydrochloric acid bath be
pumped into its enclosure her but then
withdrew that proposal on fears it would
surely use whatever delivery mechanism
into the enclosure as a means of Escape
further suggestions put forward for the
matter include using microwave emitters
to remotely heat the interior of the
unit and the use of high volume high
intensity Sonic equipment proven to
inhabit concentration staff is also
instructed to assist in this effort by
channeling positive thoughts
incorporating the demise and destruction
of
scp-1447-1 positive slogans are posted
in the hallways and break rooms around
the facility to assist in positive
thinking weekly therapy visits for all
staff members are mandatory to ensure an
environment of strong mental health and
complementary gym memberships are given
out to employees to promote physical
well-being and motivated thinking in the
only interview on file with the human
known as
scp-1447-2 Steve Dr rolfus asked the
subject what would happen if the tulpa
were allowed to kill him
scp-1447-2 refused to answer leaving
Foundation and researchers to arrive at
two possible theories first if
scp-1447-1 destroys the human that is
responsible for its existence then
surely it too will cease to exist though
when researchers tested this Theory by
inflicting different levels of fiscal
pain to
scp-1447-2 the toppa appeared to have no
effect or change in its Behavior the
second theory and the one with a greater
support of evidence is that if the tulpa
kills
scp-1447-2 and it has already
demonstrated that it has the ability to
meditate on its own existence than its
behavior from then on out is entirely
impossible to predict at the moment its
fixation on
scp-1447-2 has been a large contributing
factor to the facility's ability to
contain it if it were to decide that its
new purpose was to bring its version of
peace to every life on the planet there
would be little the foundation could do
to stop it that outcome must be avoided
at all costs and by extension the life
of the human known as
scp-1447-2 must be protected so
hopefully you never had an imaginary
friend manifest itself into existence
and tried to kill you but what we can
all agree on is that some things are
better left in our forgotten childhood
memories now go check out
scp-5254 gotta catch em all and scp-6080
Cartoon Network for more childhood
Terrors made real